[Music]
on this thursday night from vacation
to resignation ontario's finance
minister back from barbados
a dumb dumb mistake an out of cabinet
the apology from rod phillips new
details on ottawa's new mandate for
anyone flying into canada
when it takes effect and why there's so
much confusion
and the pandemic proving to be a real
party pooper
more used to seeing it you know packed
subdued celebrations ring in 2021
and bid good riddance to 2020
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight
sonia diol good evening and thanks very
much for joining us this new year's
eve 2020 is thankfully nearly over
and many will be ringing in the new year
wishing for a better year ahead
but the pandemic is overshadowing
celebrations tonight
canadians are facing restrictions like
never before and the tough reality that
we still have a long road
to recovery here's a look at why the
numbers are so worrying
canada is seeing a sharp surge in
infections averaging around 6
000 new cases per day they're largely
driven by the two
biggest provinces quebec reported a
record number of single day
infections and ontario shattered its
previous high
reporting more than 3 000 new cases icu
admissions also reaching a pandemic
record
in ontario premier doug ford is among
the leaders facing growing pressure to
curb
the crisis today his finance minister
stepped down
hours after arriving home from a
caribbean vacation that went against
pandemic guidelines travis danraj is
following the developing details
in our top story tonight the walk of
shame through pearson international
airport for a politician who clearly
knows
he did wrong but ron phillips maya coppa
a significant error in judgment a dumb
dumb mistake was not enough to save his
job as ontario's finance minister
premier ford releasing a statement
thursday afternoon today following my
conversation with rod phillips
i have accepted his resignation as
ontario's minister of finance
at a time when the people of ontario
have sacrificed so much
today's resignation is a demonstration
that our government takes seriously our
obligation to hold ourselves to a higher
standard
very very difficult the optics of a jet
setting finance minister on a two and a
half week long pleasure trip only
returning to a province he helped put
into lockdown
after the story became public clearly
became too much for the premier to
manage
i can tell you i'm very upset he could
have put a stop to it
a couple of weeks ago instead he chose
to um
basically help rod phillips keep the
secret
that he was out of the country and the
only reason that we're
dealing with this now is because they
got caught
the optics are horrible and i don't know
what the finance minister was thinking
going off to
you know an island vacation where the
rich
and famous go to play why we're in the
middle of a crisis
so after losing his cabinet position
drawing the ire of ontarians
and drawing international attention what
now for phillips
everybody makes mistakes everybody makes
errors in judgment this was a pretty big
one
but you know if he wants a future in
politics i think he did the only thing
that he could do
that future remains unclear right now
one thing that is clear
when it comes to the big decisions for
ontario rod phillips will be watching
from the back benches
travis standrich global news travelers
arriving into canada will now be
required to provide a negative
covert 19 test as of january 7th that
date given this afternoon by the federal
government
a day after announcing the new travel
restriction
as rich as usment now reports airlines
are scrambling to comply
with only a week left to prepare
delayed flight we have been trying to
get the government
to work with us over the past six or
seven months
in developing a clear concise testing
strategy
the head of the national airlines
council of canada is frustrated
after months of advocating for a testing
strategy wednesday's federal decision
to require proof of a negative coven 19
test from air passengers
came as a surprise the whole point of
that exercise
is to avoid the the rushed uh
rushed approach and the confusion that
that will now create
and unfortunately that is the approach
we are now seeing late on thursday the
federal government providing some
details
as of january 7th all air passengers 5
years and older will be required
to have the negative test before
traveling into canada from another
country
the test must be taken within 72 hours
of flying
and the negative results must be
presented to the airline before boarding
i'm concerned that canadians who are
abroad
in jurisdictions that may not have easy
access
to pcr tests might have problems
anyone coming back will still be
required to quarantine for 14 days
the provinces are supportive of the
testing measure but quebec and british
columbia have repeatedly raised concerns
ottawa is not doing enough to ensure
those in isolation after
international travel are actually
staying there the more that can be done
to support people
and maintain that 14-day quarantine
because it's not easy but also to remind
people that that is their absolute
obligation to do so
would be helpful british columbia and
other provinces specifically concerned
about the fact
that those that are under quarantine are
not getting
frequent enough phone calls from the
federal government
especially important now that the covet
19 variant
is here in canada sonia richard zusman
in victoria thank you the moderna
vaccine is now
being ruled out in the northwest
territories a residents and staff in a
senior's home in yellowknife
are among the first in canada's north to
get this new vaccine
which is shipped and stored more easily
than the one from pfizer biontech
nunavut and yukon are expected to begin
rolling out the moderna vaccine
in the coming weeks in bc many who work
in the hospitality
industry are frustrated with a
last-minute provincial health order
to move up that last call for a drink
restaurants bars and stores have been
ordered to stop
selling alcohol at 8 00 pm tonight
the aim is to prevent big gatherings and
irresponsible behavior
often linked to late-night drinking
this decision could force some people
into bankruptcy and we can help industry
prepare for that
and people can take time to plan
something different for their business
to help keep customers safe if you give
us a bit of notice
alberta has become the first province to
officially say the nhl can play in its
arenas next year
all teams will have to follow government
health guidelines as well as rules
outlined in the league's return to play
plan there are four other provinces with
nhl teams
the league's deputy commissioner
believes the league can play in all
canadian markets
the federal government has also issued
an exemption to the mandatory 14-day
quarantine period
for nhl players and staff returning to
canada
for training camps citing national
interest
americans will be ringing in the new
year overwhelmed by a pandemic that has
now claimed more than 352
000 lives doctors are urging people once
again
to stay home for the first time the
iconic celebration
in new york's times square will be
eerily empty
without the usual crowds of spectators
as jennifer johnson now reports
covert 19 has led to the deadliest year
in the country's history
the iconic crystal ball set to drop at
midnight in new york's times square
but this year there will be no
spectators to cheer it on new year's eve
you never hopefully you're never going
to see this again times square like this
one million people who usually pack the
streets have been told to stay home
because of covet 19
but the show will go on the tradition
remains the same we're still going to
see this beautiful waterford crystal
ball lowered as the entire world counts
down together
united with a single wish for a good new
year for everyone
just a few dozen frontline workers have
been invited to attend the event
in a city that's projected to lose 1.5
billion dollars in tourism sales for
2021
but with most hospitals filled up again
officials say they had no choice
i'm covert fatigued i get it but you
know this is a war
and you can't get fatigued before the
enemy gets fatigued
according to kaiser health statistics
2020 has become america's deadliest year
in history
topping 3 million including over 340
000 covet 19 deaths doctors are
encouraging much quieter new year's eve
celebrations
as the virus continues its rampage even
if someone says
they've tested negative the biggest
misconception of this pandemic
is that i got tested today and therefore
i'm safe tomorrow or the next day
remember that the incubation period is 2
to 14 days
healthcare workers say those insisting
on celebrating with others
need to take precautions let's all wear
masks and do social distancing that will
help
bend the curve and make the new year a
happier one
but experts say with 85 million people
traveling over the holidays
the next surge is coming most are
predicting january 2021
will be the country's deadliest month
since the pandemic began
jennifer johnson global news washington
the fbi is investigating a wisconsin
hospital worker who spoiled more than
500 doses of the maternal covert 19
vaccine
by deliberately removing vials from a
pharmacy fridge
the incident happened over the weekend
at the aurora medical center in grafton
that is north of milwaukee
the employee has now been fired there's
no word yet on a motive
it's the end of an era for the uk as the
country is now
officially broken away from the european
union british prime minister boris
johnson
signed the post-brexit trade deal with
the eu on wednesday
it means that britain now has
economically and
practically left the 27 nation block
it's been four and a half years since
britain voted in a referendum to
leave the eu johnson says the uk now
has freedom in its hands
so you are having your cake and eating
it you said it we will be able to do
things
differently we'll be able to find ways
of being
more competitive if we want to be
the deal grants the uk access to one of
the largest
free trade blocs in the world in return
britain has agreed to what's known as
the level
playing field which means following
environmental and workers standards
laid out by the european union coming up
a family's heartbreaking
holiday the shocking conditions they
witnessed
inside one long-term care home
welcome back an ontario family is
speaking out after witnessing what it
calls a distressing situation
inside a niagara falls long-term care
home oakwood park lodge is dealing with
a major covert 19
outbreak more than 225 residents and
staff
have been infected in just over two
weeks 24 people
have died morgan campbell reports
this is how gibson penny and his family
spent their boxing day
holding their loved one as she took her
last breath
i can't even talk to her and say one
last goodbye this is how the penny
family
would prefer to remember a vet brock a
kind
selfless woman with a creative streak
the 81 year old lived at oakwood park
lodge in niagara falls
her family says the experience there was
an ordeal
with conflicting reports about her
medical condition
and miscommunication recounting the
experience through the front door of
their oshawa home
the pennies who are in isolation say
they couldn't believe what they saw
behind the walls of this
long-term care home when we left there
was a resident in
the hallway in a wheelchair asking us to
bring the water
and it was like a ghost town you know
there was there was no staff inside
the pair say they also witnessed a
resident sleeping
in the lobby the kovid 19 outbreak has
led to the deaths of more than 20
residents
and infected dozens of others niagara
health recently stepped in
and took over management of the home
owned and operated by
con med healthcare group which also owns
millennium trail manor
where 15 seniors have died with the
virus
a joint statement from oakwood park
lodge and
niagara health says they have assessed
the home writing
our hospital team is working closely
with the oakwood launch team on a number
of priority areas
this ranges from clinical care to
managing personal protective equipment
to
infection prevention and enhanced
cleaning
during a briefing at queen's park
wednesday the associate medical officer
of health explained
that military and red cross supports are
on the table these are all
considerations
i can't tell you the exact breaking
point a spokesperson with the ministry
of long-term care
reiterated that the province is
recruiting staff to help assist the
sector
which members of the opposition say
should have been done sooner
if we would have invested that money if
he wouldn't invest in psw's
they'd still be here they'd be able to
celebrate christmas with their family
the penny family only decided to go
public with their story in an effort to
shed light on the plates faced by not
just residents but staff working
in long-term care morgan campbell global
news
sad news out of ontario where its
patient ombudsman has died in a tragic
accident
kathy fuchs assumed her role in july
during the pandemic
today premier doug ford praised her as a
champion who fought tirelessly to
improve the patient
and family caregiver experience in our
healthcare system
still ahead nova scotians trying to heal
from a year that's given them one
tragedy
after another
well 2020 has been a tough year for many
of us but for nova scotians it's been
especially hard the province is not only
in the middle of a pandemic
as ross lord explains it's struggling to
come to terms with the year's
other heartbreaking tragedies on land
and at sea
the natural beauty of nova scotia is
undisturbed but the soul of this
province has been darkened
the anxiety felt by all canadians in
2020
can't compare to the blanket of grief
here an anguish that's stricken everyone
i've cried more
in the last 10 months than certainly i
did in the first seven years of my job
but really probably ever mourning dozens
of deaths from covet 19
and a string of other tragedies i think
we are requesting
more ambulances probably one more coming
and then at least one more standby only
a few weeks into the pandemic
came april's hideous massacre a
denturist
dressed up like a mountie killed 13
people in the tiny village of portopic
he killed nine more people in other
communities the next day
before being shot dead by police this
grief counselor says
devastation from the slaughter is
unshakable it's changed
um there's uh i mean i feel it when i'm
out on my walks
there's a beauty and a sadness all
intertwined now
before the end of april tragedy struck
again a navy helicopter based in halifax
crashed off the coast of greece all six
people on board were killed in the prime
of their lives
including navy sub-lieutenant abigail
cobra then there's the more personal
items you know walking her down the
aisle when she decides to get married
first child those types of things that
just
won't ever happen less than three weeks
after the helicopter went down
a canadian forces snowbirds jet crashed
after takeoff in kamloops bc
the crash killed captain jen casey a
nova scotia native
working as a public affairs officer 2020
is a year i'd like to forget and we're
not even halfway there yet
in september more distress this time in
the nova scotia lobster fishery
indigenous fishers exercising their
treaty rights
were confronted by commercial harvesters
[Applause]
commercial fishers sabotage fishing
lines a lobster pound that did business
with indigenous harvesters was burnt to
the ground
in a dispute that intensified for weeks
and is still
unresolved yet another painful episode
that made 2020
the most trying year in recent memory
i've never seen anything like it and and
you know i cried too i don't know
anybody who didn't cry
but sorrow can also inspire
dimitri nionakis used his piloting
skills to provide consolation
by recording intricate flight paths on
gps
neonak has created sky drawings like a
heart for port-a-pick
flying hundreds of kilometers for each
artistic tribute
he spelled out jen casey's name and he
traced an anchor in the sky for yet
another heartbreaking disaster
december's sinking of a scalloped dragon
near digby
which claimed the lives of six men
risking his own safety and poor flying
conditions
neonakus helped raise 60 thousand
dollars for the men's families
those messages from people who lost
their parents or lost their brother or
sister
messages they mean a lot to me those
those messages
those are the ones that they hit home
another positive
is the overall success of nova scotia
and the atlantic region
in limiting the spread of covet 19.
grief counselors
say moral victories don't erase the
impact of unimaginable tragedy
it's absolutely devastating they say
time
and space are critically important as
efforts to heal
continue into the new year ross lord
global news
halifax still ahead bidding farewell to
2020 how the world is starting a new
year
with new hope
new year's eve is often a time of
reflection and when we think of 2020
it is going to be remembered for
bringing us a pandemic unlike anything
we've experienced in our lifetimes
before
in one way or another it's had an impact
on us all
the world over for much of the globe the
year has already
ended redmond shannon takes a look at
how the planet
is ringing in 2021
normally sydney harbour is thronged with
thousands of people for new year's eve
but this year only those with restaurant
bookings were allowed up close
to see the iconic fireworks normally
there's crowds of people out and
it's a bit eerie this evening with new
virus clusters in the city
authorities asked aussies to watch from
home
although clearly not everyone listened
[Music]
the sensoji temple bell rang in 2021 in
tokyo
a year the city hopes to host a delayed
olympics
daily cases of covet 19 have topped 1
000 in japan's capital for the first
time
and the governor has warned of an
explosion of cases
[Music]
in north korea little is known about the
extent of the pandemic
the crowds were dense but absolutely
everyone wore their mask
above their nose was leaked
german chancellor angela merkel called
2020 the most difficult of her 15 years
in office
taking aim at what she called cruel and
dangerous covet 19 conspiracy theories
in france an 8 p.m curfew was in place
with
dj david guetta playing a fundraising
gig from the louvre
this woman said she instead would be in
bed by eight
but in true french style would eat well
first
in london the traditional party spot of
trafalgar square opposite canada house
is off limits
most of the uk is in hard lockdown
catherine ryan
youtube uk has an online party hosted by
canadian comedian catherine ryan
join me with a few of my friends
somewhat optimistically encouraging
young people to party at home but wait
there is hope
jump back to the very start of the day
[Applause]
auckland new zealand no masks no worries
effectively covet free a sign of what
next new year's eve could be like
for all of us redmond shannon global
news london
and that is global national for this
thursday night and for 2020
i'm sonia dion for our final goodbye
we're going to
go out in style
[Music]
these goats are milking the party for
all it's worth
bleating in the new year from their home
in tennessee
rumor has it they'll be dancing to billy
vanilli
tonight on behalf of dorner robin and
the entire global national team wishing
you a very safe
and happy new year i'll see you back
here tomorrow
don't note
[Music]